le texte qui vous a été transmis venant
de l'Assemblée nationale au sens textuel
du terme est à l'équilibre
un certain nombre de mesures ont été
discutées et votées en commission qui
coûte évidemment pour notre système de
retraite je sais que nous recherchons
tous l'équilibre du système et nous nous
souhaitons pas alourdir davantage son
déficit nous devrons donc pouvoir
discuter de façon approfondie et sereine
au cours de nos débats je pense d'abord
à l'amendement permettant aux assurés
ayant obtenu au moins un trimestre de
majoration durée d'assurance au titre de
la maternité de l'adoption ou de
l'éducation des enfants et justifiant
d'une carrière complète à 63 ans de
s'ouvrir des droits assurcotte sans
devoir attendre l'âge de 64 ans nous
aurons nous aurons évidemment ce débat
mais la première ministre a rappelé
notre ouverture vis-à-vis de mesure de
bonification pour les femmes et qui
contribuent à gommer les écarts dans le
niveau des pensions les évaluations sont
encore en train d'être affinés mais le
coût d'une telle mesure est évidemment
très important
s'agissant de la proposition de
maintenir à 60 ans l'âge minimum de
départ en retraite anticipé pour
incapacité permanente elle représente
combinée aux ajustements permettant à
davantage d'assurer d'être éligible à ce
dispositif présenté en texte initiale un
surcoût de plus de 250 millions d'euros
à horizon 2030 dont 100 millions d'euros
pour le système de retraite je pense
aussi à l'amendement prévoyant le
maintien de l'âge d'éligibilité à la
retraite progressive à 60 ans au lieu de
son report à 62 ans qui coûte un peu
plus de 100 millions d'euros en 2030
s'agissant des mesures visant à
favoriser le recrutement des seniors je
sais que la commission des affaires
sociales a proposé la création d'un
contrat de fin de carrière ouvert aux
salariés d'au moins 60 ans ce contrat a
duré indéterminé serait exonéré de
cotisation famille par ailleurs le
dispositif prévoit la possibilité pour
l'employeur de mettre à la retraite le
salarié si ce dernier remplit les
conditions pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein
je vois bien l'idée qui est de inciter
les employeurs à recruter des seniors et
à les maintenir dans l'entreprise
jusqu'à ce que ces derniers puissent
liquider leur pensions là encore si je
comprends l'intention des rapporteurs je
souhaite alerter sur le coup
considérable d'une telle mesure qui
pourrait avoisiner les 800 millions
d'euros selon selon une première
estimation provisoire mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre il y a par
ailleurs un risque d'effet de seuil si
j'additionne les coûts de chacune de ces
mesures en retenant en ne retenant que
celles dans les conséquences financières
sont les plus importantes l'équilibre
financier de notre système à horizon
2030 s'éloigne indubitablement et je
veux le dire clairement nous souhaitons
pouvoir respecter cet équilibre
soyons clairs parler de dépenses
supplémentaires n'a jamais été un tabou
mais ce qui nous perdons de vu
l'équilibre financier du régime de
retraite une réforme serait non
seulement vaine mais contre-productive
[Musique]